Terra is in Miami hi Tara
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
my mom told me about your show so I want
to call in I'm 50 years old I have too
many teenage sons I'm divorced and we're
closing on the cellular marital home
zone my portion is 1.2 million I need
advice about what to do with it why I
need a plan yeah I'm excited by this
problem yeah where are you living
were you living in the house is this yes
yes we divorced but he allowed me to
stay in it a little bit longer you know
for the boys sake and now we're finally
you know closing on it soon obviously
you're gonna need a house right well I'm
renting for the first year I just feel
like I want to do that I don't know dude
that's what I need to know what to do
with that money do I buy within a year
do i Vesely cv I don't even know what I
can't afford to buy so I just really
need a plan what do you are you making
here a 120 boy I go good okay and so
what does the what the hell posture the
house that you're selling what it is so
for a 2.45 car so each other yeah yeah
and it was paid for yes it was paid for
we live smart yeah you did your dad well
but I want to go some more to be smart
moving forward and I'll just he did all
the finances that I didn't so I'm just
kind of lost you know I know that here's
what I know you guys were obviously
married probably 20 plus years right yes
we were mm-hmm so when you can this is
um you're talking about it in a cheerful
voice but there's a you guys have you've
either processed or you are processing a
lot of hurt no it's all good it really
is because we're so just it's all about
the children and there's no egos
involved so it's all
I mean you have to be grieving a 20
years something ending if you're not
you're weird yeah yeah I'm it's sad sad
but we're all happy and we're all in a
good place
okay all right good I'm glad I don't
want you to be sad I'm just um anyway my
point is I want you to make good clear
decisions and that's what I was checking
in on because sometimes when you're
hurting you don't make you're in the fog
of the pain and you don't worse now
we've been separate since 2013 and
different years now you just allowed us
to stay in the house I'm sorry I was
miss reading okay all right anyway so
good well that's good news then so now
here's the thing the the less debt that
you have like you've already discovered
and earlier in your life before you ever
heard my name the less debt you have two
things happen one is it's easier to
build wealth because you don't have
payments and two is you're much more
stable there's less stress I agree
wholeheartedly yeah I don't I don't have
any debt except the car payment and now
my new condo rental okay so I would pay
off my car today I would never come well
it's only I'm leasing okay well I'd call
them asking what it takes to get out of
the lease and pay it off if you want to
keep it I don't know I don't want any
payments at all the second thing they're
going to consider then is when I buy if
you want to wait a year that's okay but
when I buy can you live in a 1 million
dollar house and pay cash for it I don't
know if I could I don't know if I can
afford to do that I don't know that's
what I need to know what you've been
living in a two and a half million
dollar house and I'm suggesting a
million dollar house that's a bit of a
drop yeah
India I mean yeah and you don't get that
much for a million at the shower I don't
I know I know the miami market it's an
expensive market okay so anyway that's
something to think through because if I
could have if I gotta have you debt free
at 50 years old making 120 going forward
you can retire multi-man
I am 950 I know but if you have you
debt-free in the house you're living in
once you make your home purchase going
forward making a hundred twenty thousand
you can be a multi-millionaire when you
get ready to retire and but but it to
the extent I put you into a mortgage or
let you or suggest you go back into a
mortgage that's one more thing we got to
clean up that's between us and building
wealth so if you want to rent for a year
and park it into a CD and decide what to
do that's what I would consider doing
during that time I'm gonna really think
about where I could live and pay cash
because you've got a million dollars and
even in a tough market like Miami
meaning an expensive market you probably
can find something and then without a
house payment without a car payment with
a little money in the bank for
emergencies and making 120 a year you
can start investing and if you just
invest the equivalent of most people's
house payment and you invest fifteen
percent of your income on top of that
those two things alone by the time
you're seventy will be millions and
millions of dollars and so that's what I
would love to see you move towards and
so I don't mind you renting for a year
and thinking about where you want to
land but that would be my target it
would not be a million-and-a-half house
with a million dollar downpayment I
still got a half a million dollars to
clean up before I get to really become
wealthy and I'd rather not I'd rather
not and that that's a way I look at it
so you got to consider those things and
that'll get you going